10 dans le lied adjani réponse dans une
seconde aujourd'hui bonsoir tu
t'attendais un tel succès pour pour
décalage son dernier album
non pas parce que tu as fait tes adieux
tafer s'il ya beaucoup de succès puis
partir quand même c'est génial
ils sont non c'est vrai mais fois
maintenant je me remet très bien mais
c'est bien alors non mais tu as fait tes
adieux et puis on le voit partout c'est
pas désagréable
j'ai pas fait mais à viella j'ai dit que
ce serait le dernier disent qu'il faut
l'exploiter encore un petit pas d'accord
exploit
j'écris pour est alors tu as dit une
fois pour moi faire des émissions de
télé c'est une torture c'est terrible le
renault lui s'en fout il n'a pas besoin
de faire de télé pour vendre un million
de dispute a vu ce qui s'est passé il
n'a pas voulu faire de télé il n'a pas
produit un million de disques
moi je le pauvre tu le plat oui je vais
mettre un cierge pour lui dire qu'il n'a
pas eu ça s'est très mal passé était au
courant comme un titre comme quoi il
faut être torturés quand on est artiste
passionné m'intéresse pas donc très près
la carrière de renault tu es très
capricorne parce que tu as dit une fois
une phrase que je trouve assez c'est
bien payé la vie est terrifiante
mais j'aime je me dis ça peut s'y
connaît un nouveau jalon dans sa bande
ont aussi dire
j'aime la capricorne c'est donc jean
rabat joie ouais on t'appelle tu sais tu
que les escaliers je connais ton surnom
la grande non olympique
les dimanches en à voile a su faire à ma
joie tu as entendu parler des questions
des questions cons
[Musique]
par exemple imagine que tu puisses avoir
quelque chose en plus en plus en plus tu
préfèrerais avoir donné 200 3 où je
crois que jacques préféré que j'ai deux
sexes de ces imagine que tu sois
enceinte de nouveau oui chance ce sera
un plaisir tu fais une échographie et on
te dit voilà votre petit
mais il a deux sexes il a donné où il ya
trois yeux qu'est ce que tu ferais tu te
feras avorter ou tutu le garderais parce
que finalement ces cas là c'est comme ça
je regarderai pas tu garderait pas tu
fais comme hitler alors que tu les gens
qui sont pas normaux qua non mais je
crois qu'on a effectivement on avait les
moyens d'empêcher un être d'avoir une
vie vraiment défavorisés il faut
utiliser ses moyens
tu rentres chez toi soir et tu trouves
jacques dutronc au lit avec isabelle
adjani mais ton joyeux où tu appelles
paris match je me joins à eux ils
médiature mois la travailliste internet
je n'ai rien contre les amours saphiques
à leur salaire dans ces conditions la
wii avec isabelle adjani ça va oui oui à
condition que jacques soit là aussi
vous séparer avec jacques sur cette
triste ou séparé le pauvre thomas il se
retrouve tout seul
pourquoi il sera tout seul sinon c'est
pas toi aussi enfin bon tout le monde ce
secteur il faut le confier à quelqu'un
c'est un jeu est-ce que tu préférais
qu'il soit confié à karine cheryl à
chantal goya ou à dorothée ça c'est un
s'était jeté sur wii un dilemme ailleurs
tout à fait crever j'ai bien je ne sais
pas du tout je sais déjà que toi sale
mère nourricière à qui voudrait tuer
soit confié le projet confié à chantal
goya parce que c'est la seule que je
connaisse des tramways
c'est la seule qui ait des enfants ouais
enfin sa vie à la télé en plus chantal
goya dont qu'elle s'occuperait du monde
c'est bon ça enfin je crois qu'il
faudrait surtout demandé invitera en
l'occurrence
ah bon je crois qu'il préférait se passe
est sceptique
non non je lui posais une question
encore plus con c'est possible tu es tu
prisonnière et les gens qui te tiennent
comme ça géôliers t'oblige à faire
l'amour avec un animal terrible s'est
jamais pensé non ça jamais tu vas y
penser pour la première fois ce soir il
était temps à ton âge est ce que tu
préfèrerais un cochon est un cochon
on verra donc au chaud
un chien ou un âne bien tout en temps tu
peux réfléchir on a le temps là vraiment
c'est très dur là c'est quand même moins
bien qu'ils avalent est générale
oui c'est autre chose j'ai la vie de
réserve find go bonne surprise je sais
pas j'aime beaucoup les ânes moi je
trouve ça très vite avant tu prendrais
la briche prendrait d'accord c'est bien
c'est la corse
j'avais un plaisir à 10,3 alors
maintenant si tu devais dîner avec
quelqu'un t'a pas le choix d'être obligé
de dîner avec lui et a pas d'autre
solution
tu préfèrerais dîner avec un sourd muet
ou avec un aveugle bdj bien
l'aveuglé bec mais ce que je pourrais
partir en dernière question con
françoise hardy oui quel fameux trou
c'est une question à l'ajax france
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
leonard itude abonnez vous mettez un
pouce bleus